hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his fifth
meditation Rene Descartes is going to
provide another argument for God's
existence you'll remember that he
provides his first main argument in the
course of the third meditation some
people want to say that there's an
argument in the first meditation but
there's some controversy about that and
if there is it's a much weaker argument
than the ones that are provided in the
third and then again in the fifth
meditation and this arises out of
decart's consideration of what he calls
true and immutable ideas so we'll talk
about that in a moment but first we
should talk about what kind of argument
is this as opposed to the argument in
the third meditation which is a little
bit hard to shoehorn into the now
traditional categories and philosophy of
religion of ontological arguments
cosmological arguments and teleological
or design arguments and then the
miscellaneous box of all the other ones
that you could throw things into the
arguments in meditation 5 is very very
clearly an ontological argument and I
should point out that the term
ontological argument was not around at
the time that Descartes was writing or
the other
more famous originator of something
generally taken to be an ontological
argument and some of Canterbury it comes
later on with with cons and all of his
successors but this notion of an
argument that would work from the idea
of God or this this technique you could
say was already long established by the
time that Descartes himself is
considering it so what are ontological
arguments essentially what makes an
argument for the existence of God an
ontological argument is that you start
from the idea of God so you have to say
what this idea
consists in and then there's something
unique about that idea as you unpack it
that says that the idea of God has to be
different than other ideas in that the
object of that idea namely God must
necessarily exist not possibly exists
not provides good inductive grounds
you're saying listen we've got this idea
there's something unique about this idea
when we look at it that the thing that
the idea is of must necessarily have
being or existence and in this case
Descartes is in fact at least in the
French translation using the term
existence so it's very clear that this
is an ontological argument it doesn't
work by looking at the world or
causality or anything like that it
doesn't work by looking for any sort of
design in nature it doesn't say that it
would be better to have a God than not
to have a god or that virtue must be
rewarded or anything along those lines
it says there's something peculiar about
this idea that when we look at it
carefully we realize that the thing of
which we have the idea must necessarily
exist so how does it work for decart he
talks about there being an infinity of
ideas perhaps having no existence
outside of his thought and he calls
these true an immutable nature
right there the nature's of things and
so in an example of this is the triangle
it could be that there's no triangles in
existence however as soon as we start
thinking about a triangle we realized
that its angles must add up to 180
degrees
or to use the old parlance for this that
it's angles must be equal to two right
angles right doesn't assert it doesn't
assure us or assert that there actually
are existing triangles but we've got
them as true and immutable natures of
which we have ideas within our mind he
says that considering this this leads us
to a new possibility says a
demonstrative proof of the existence of
God and how does this work so it's a
very interesting proof and this is
another little bit of a digression here
quite often ontological arguments are
not so simple as saying hey you got this
idea look at the idea what there's
existence in the idea they were done
they work by way of saying okay we've
got this idea the idea does include
existence but somebody else might say
that's just nonsense
there's all sorts of things that we can
think of and we might even think of them
existing it doesn't make that actually
be the case and so Descartes considers
that as a possibility that's part of the
argument and you don't want to just
strip it aside and say oh we're only
going to focus on the negative or the
positive part of the argument you do
want to take the negative into
consideration there's a reason why it's
built in there both in Descartes and in
his in this case predecessor and some so
the argument says we have this idea of a
supremely perfect being
now the Curtis talked about this earlier
what is it to be a supremely perfect
being a being that actually has all
perfections so these would include
things like omniscience or you know
complete goodness on me but benevolence
or you know whatever it else it is that
you want to
put in there whatever it is that it's
best to be or better to be than not to
be to use an Psalms formulation from the
Mona lo Jian and also in the pro so Jian
chapter 5 for example you'll you'll
you'll put that into that idea and say
that that that's part of it so he says
that I have this idea of a being whose
sovereignly or you know supremely
perfect and I know this that I know no
less clearly and distinctly that now
here's where it gets quite interesting
in the French that an actual and eternal
existence belongs to that nature I know
this no more no less clearly and
distinctly he says then that I know
anything that I can demonstrate about
any figure or number actually truly
belongs to the nature that figure or
that number so I know just as clearly as
I do about mathematics or geometry which
is really you know for decart sort of
the the high point the hallmark of clear
and distinct ideas I know that actual
and eternal existence must belong to God
to the idea of God I know what belongs
in there now I said this is really
interesting because when we look at the
Latin it doesn't actually say actual and
eternal existence remember Descartes
wrote the meditations originally in
Latin and then they were translated by
somebody else into French he looked over
the translation says looks good to be
and so that sometimes there's going to
be some interesting differences here so
he says here we go neck monoski lottery
at distinct day and tell ago odd is not
Twitter I'm Peter toon iterate
okay so up to that point it's the same
would send better exist that that it
always exists so
you know is this a bad translation it's
not a bad translation but there is a
divergence there from the lat
he's just saying what's in the idea is
that this being always exists sent
better exists that and notice that he
doesn't say semper or asked right or a
set
it always has being he's saying it
always exists it always exists in in the
world or outside of us you could say so
that's part of that nature
then he points out he says well that
means that God has to exist because it's
part of God's nature to exist now at
that point somebody could say whoa
Descartes that seems like a bit of a
stretch you're building into this idea
exactly what you're looking for that
sounds like a circular argument to me or
the way that he's gonna call it a
sophism this seems to be a sophism why
because he says when it comes to things
we are accustomed to make a distinction
between existence and essence so I
easily persuade myself that the
existence can be separated from the
essence of God and that we can conceive
of God is not actually being so wouldn't
this mean that there's a fatal flaw with
the argument and Descartes says let's go
further with this consider some of the
examples that that you've got like the
triangle right triangle has if it the
triangle exists it has to have these
properties that's in the idea of the
triangle that you have in your mind that
doesn't actually mean that a triangle
exists or even if you want to say that
doesn't mean that a thing with the
properties that you're talking about
exists let's consider another example he
says you can have a mountain and if you
have a mountain you gotta have a valley
right you can't have the one without the
other
but there's nothing that says that you
have to have a mountain in the first
place so even though being adjacent to
valleys I guess that would be the
property there would be something that
is necessarily a property of the
mountain you know there's no reason why
you have to have an existing mountain
can't you imagine a world that's
completely flat no mountains no valleys
so if we put it that way
it seems like we've actually made some
sort of mistake right so he says there's
no left there are there's there's a ya
know less repugnant and conceiving of a
God that is a being who's supremely
perfect - which existence is lacking
that is to say to which there there's
some sort of perfection lacking then
there would be of conceiving a mountain
without any valley and now that kind of
gave it away though didn't he right and
saying that because if that being is
lacking existence then it is lacking a
perfection and it's no longer a being
possessing all the perfections that
we're considering here is it so it's not
exactly like the triangle or the
mountain valley combination and
Descartes will say that you know there's
actually a sophism contained in this
objection that we're making so you know
what what is it he says that from the
fact that I cannot conceive of a
mountain without a valley it doesn't
follow that there is in the world any
mountain nor any Valley but only that
the mountain and the valley if there
were any weather there aren't any cannot
in any fashion be separated one from the
other in place of that he says from the
mere fact that I cannot conceive of God
lacking existence songs existence right
he says it follows that existence is
inseparable from God and that he truly
very table mall
in French exists not that my thought
makes it be of this sort as if it
imposed on things any sort of necessity
but to the contrary because the NASA the
necessity of the thing itself that is to
say the existence of God determines my
thought to conceive of it in that manner
so he says it is not in my my freedom of
conceiving a God without existence that
is a being who saw readily perfect
without a sovereign perfection as it is
for me to imagine for example a horse
with you know without wings or with
wings or anything like that there's
something distinctive again about this
idea so existence winds up being
inseparable for God for the idea of God
and this leads us to the point of seeing
that God therefore must exist there's
one other thing that he does point out
that's kind of interesting about this he
tells us that not only must God
necessarily exist but that the idea of
God turns out to be as he calls it the
image of a true and immutable nature he
says first off because I cannot conceive
of anything other than God itself for
whom the essence of this existence
belongs lessons that quell existence
belongs with necessity and this also
leads them to another interesting
corollary he says because of this God
must be unique there can't be two or
more gods only this idea can be the idea
of God a being supremely or sovereignly
perfect that is possessing every single
perfection which necessarily includes
existence
and you might even say inseparable
existence so there may be some problems
with this but you've now seen what des
cartes argument is this ontological
argument for the existence of God that
he is presenting to us in meditation
five
you